-Performing her late father,
Chris Cornell's,
cover of "Nothing Compares 2 U"
off his album
"No One Sings Like You Anymore,"
both of which are nominated
for Grammys,
here's Toni Cornell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It's been
7 hours and 15 days ♪
♪ Since you took
your love away ♪
♪ I go out every night
and sleep all day ♪
♪ Since you took your
love away ♪
♪ Since you been gone,
I can do whatever I want ♪
♪ I can see whoever I choose ♪
♪ I can eat my dinner in
a fancy restaurant ♪
♪ But nothing ♪
♪ I said nothing
can take away these blues ♪
♪ 'Cause nothing compares ♪
♪ Nothing compares to you ♪
♪ It's been so
lonely without you here ♪
♪ Like a bird without a song ♪
♪ Nothing can stop these
lonely tears from falling ♪
♪ Tell me, baby,
where did I go wrong? ♪
♪ I could throw my arms around
every boy I see ♪
♪ But they'd
only remind me of you ♪
♪ I went to the doctor,
and guess what he told me ♪
♪ Guess what he told me ♪
♪ He said, "Girl,
you better try to have fun
no matter what you do" ♪
♪ But he's a fool ♪
♪ 'Cause nothing compares ♪
♪ Nothing compares to you ♪
♪ All the flowers that
you planted, mama ♪
♪ In the backyard ♪
♪ All died when you went away ♪
♪ I know that living with you,
baby, was sometimes hard ♪
♪ But I'm willing to
give it another try ♪
♪ 'Cause nothing compares ♪
♪ Nothing compares to you ♪
♪ Nothing compares ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]